euh Tina Turner elle était extrêmement
riche hein oui plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros on parle d'un
héritage qui serait en estimé ce n'est
qu'une estimation entre 250 et 400
millions d'euros voilà reste à savoir
comment c'est héritage va être réparti
et là c'est la grande question comment
entre 250 et 400 millions d'euros voilà
alors la grande question c'est si elle
résidait ensuite elle s'était mariée en
2013 avec un Allemand et les aider à
Zurich si c'est le droit suisse qui
s'applique à ce moment-là l'héritage va
au Marie et aux deux enfants qui restent
les deux enfants adoptés voilà et aux
autres personnes uniquement s'il y aura
une mention sur un testament ça c'est le
droit suisse s'applique alors
effectivement il a une une chose qui est
complètement correcte
quand tu es marié en Suisse c'est une
loi qui est différente je crois qu'à peu
près 47% qui va à l'époux et le reste
aux enfants mais comme les deux enfants
de Tina donc Greg et Rony elle n'a
jamais reconnu elle n'a jamais adopté à
junior qui est mon beau-frère c'était
juste parce qu'elle est avec Ike et
qu'ils étaient dans la famille donc ils
ne sont pas du tout on les a jamais
adoptés
les seuls Bloods comme on dit le seul
sang les descendants de Turner était
Craig erroni et aujourd'hui j'ai le
sentiment et je suis la seule avec le
nom Turner puisqu'il n'y a plus
d'auteurneur et c'est pour ça que j'ai
vraiment envie d'honorer ce nom et de
respecter mes beaux-parents et mon runny
et Craig donc
préciser juste par rapport à la loi
suisse et j'en suis désolé Hafida la loi
suisse ne reconnaît pas dans ces cas-là
la belle-fille
non je dis pas que vous êtes là
par respect pour ma belle-mère et si
venu
respecter merci
on m'a jamais rien donné
est-ce qu'à un moment tu l'as pas dit
j'aimerais faire tel télé est-ce que tu
peux m'aider à faire signer est-ce que
tu peux m'aider à faire ça à rencontrer
telle ou telle personne jamais
c'est-à-dire qu'elle m'a il y a eu un
contrat qui devait être fait quand elle
a écouté mec miser et French Kiss il y a
des choses que je ne peux pas vous dire
qui sont d'ailleurs
bon pour moi c'est ça joue en ma faveur
je ne pourrais pas vous le dire belle
vous m'avez beaucoup plus aidé à
m'inviter sur C8 merci d'ailleurs oui
vous m'avez toujours invité à chanter
mes chansons s'est mis à passer mon clip
non
j'ai pas demandé à ma belle-mère
fais-moi un chèque de demi on ça
n'existe pas
et non mais non mais
l'album en 2009 j'ai fait tout toute
seule voilà je ne suis pas là pour
parler de la fortune de ma belle-mère
parce que j'aimerais respecter son deuil
chafique non bah non non
vous avez dit il y a des choses que j'ai
faites qui jouent à ma faveur qu'est-ce
que
c'est à dire que elle trouvait que
j'avais beaucoup de choses
et que
je ne peux pas dire voilà qu'est-ce que
toujours aimé lui dire à Tina Turner tu
lui as jamais dit je lui ai tout dit
je peux pas vous dire on a toujours eu
un côté des rapports assez privé voilà
non je peux c'est vrai que j'aurais
voulu j'aurais voulu qu'elle soit plus
proche de ses fils et j'aurais voulu
qu'on passe plus de temps et j'aurais
voulu que qu'elle soit plus aux
États-Unis mais ça c'est un fait c'est
comme ça c'est pour ça que tu l'as tu la
bousculé un peu quand tu me dis je
l'engueuler un peu parfois c'était pour
ça
je suis là pour rendre hommage à ma
belle-mère je suis dans les dossiers
familiaux mais bon voilà respectable
envie de l'avoir plus non pas moi
j'étais pas la mère de créer Véronique
quoi à un moment donné je devais tu
imagines retrouver des corps des enfants
faire les enterrements enfin moi j'en
peux plus quoi c'est trop dur c'est trop
dur c'est compliqué moi j'ai déjà eu
beaucoup de souffrance en tant
qu'orpheline ce que je dois aussi porter
tous ces raconter ton histoire ah ben la
connais par cœur bien sûr
c'est pour ça qu'elle trouvait que
j'étais très courageuse mais là le
problème c'est pas moi je suis pas ici
de parler de moi je suis venue ici pour
rendre hommage à ma belle-mère et Nikon
et continuer la legacie du nom Turner et
l'Honoré